kids this saturday night two days i'll
be in madison wisconsin for two shows at
the barrymore sunday night i am at
chicago at the vic theatre for two shows
and then march 11th with christian
nashville and march 12th in chattanooga
good dates christy comedy.com for me we
got tomorrow night at the borgata
february 26 atlantic city march 4th
royal oak michigan march 5th gramercy
special taping march 11th of course with
sally v at the ryman
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
what are your nicknames because you have
a good last name for nickname do people
call you like rudds yeah just rud
rednets
people go radnitsk i like rednecks i
like redness you called me ronitsk on on
your podcast immediately probably yeah
yeah yeah on my podcast
yeah do you like pasta i i do like pasta
wow but you don't eat it no i i i eat it
but you know then i just moderately try
to walk it off
with the moderation
sometimes moderation but i do stress
is it hot in here
yeah is it a little hot in here
what is that what is going on oh my god
you do not have a pinky that glitters is
gone oh my god
no
and it says chrissy with the bracelet
with the chain wow
when did that happen it happened for uh
valentine's day that was my gift
you got that as a gift i got that as a
gift yes you got a pinky ring as a gift
yeah unironically
yeah she was dead serious about it i
love it love it no i want to make sure
it's on ironic because that makes it so
much cooler if it's authentic she goes
you're going to love it and she goes we
got to go pick it up i was like okay
where do we pick it up she said the
staten island mall that's amazing you're
the second person i know that's a pink
ring you know the other one is oh my dad
wow yeah when he gets dressed up on
special occasions religious occasions
figurine comes out what it is yeah wow
yes you me and your dad we have a lot of
things in common
with you staten island and get one of
them
you want you want we have a guy
yeah shout out i think it's casale uh
jewelers i think oh i know cassal
yeah or it might not be because oh jeff
jewelers is what it is well strike
yourself
yeah but it sounds good too
i bought you a nameplate too when you
did you love your name plate i have that
upstairs it was what all the guido kids
were in like eighth grade it was like
it's like a nameplate with your name
carved into it and it has a playboy
bunny and like what like a heart on this
one yeah it's fantastic and it says it
says my name in that plate and it's it's
just i i don't wear jewels i feel
beautiful to have um to have really
everything's coming together in my life
now with my jewelry my home yeah yeah my
vaccine status
jewelry collection is
with jewelry i i haven't but now i'm
reconsidering you own jewelry outside of
a watch i i don't me neither i don't own
anything no no i gotta get out to staten
island and change it up here's the thing
i love about you not only does it have
the perfect body type yeah no here's
what the hair is
it's bradley cooper it's it's not
everyone can have that that's what i
want instead i went with the colombian
mullet but i do like
yes
it's called the seven in some cultures
so i made a oopsie with this one but
we're going to live we're going to live
with this yeah you you've actually
changed your look you got a pink earring
now you got to smell it now it matches
the pinky ring i'm shooting a special
march 5th gramercy theater in new york
city and i wanted to stand out so i
think i'm doing a little too much
but i'm going to do it after march 5th
when the special's over in the can i'd
like to try to get to i want to become
this
if you look at me and i'm staring at you
don't think it's weird i'm just pining
for you i'll take it
was that a choice or does it just
naturally like that no no the pandemic
kind of just resulted in but people tell
you all the time you have a great head
of hair right i'm happy with the you
hear what's going on i never grew it out
i always did what you're doing yeah yeah
but you got the same head of hair you
have product in right now no product in
there that's no product i just don't
shampoo
that much okay so you have a dirty hair
that's not
no stinky hair
they say that you're not supposed to
wash your hair supposed to wash it like
a couple times a week because the
natural oil once twice a week every time
i get in the shower it doesn't matter if
i take three showers a day i wash my
hair every time shampoo and condition
that's not good i have to think about
doing it less yeah and then it comes out
more like that it'll come out more like
that it's good that you hit it with
condition if you wash it every time it's
a little conditioned yeah a little
condition you do shampoo every day but
you can don't shampoo every day and i
don't condition every day but you can do
a little condition on your off days nice
what products do you use what shampoo
and conditioner do you you know i i
don't really have a special kind of
shampoo really you just go in whatever's
at the market ever what's ever there
garnier fructis
okay whatever it is you have you look
like a leading man he that's the leading
man here that's what hollywood wants
yeah they don't want they don't want
this hopefully hollywood's watching also
you guys perfect five o'clock shadow if
we're making it uncomfortable just let
us know no i'm i'm into it okay all
right no because it's really good and i
like a dirty man and you and you've said
that you're a dirty man yeah the hairs
their hair is dirty but everything else
is scrubbed yeah everything else are you
sure about that i'm working on it last
time you got a test uh
you have a great george michael five
o'clock shadow too i have a patchy
scraggly [ __ ] i can't do it no sal you
beat yourself up too much i think you're
extremely handsome as well that's kind i
didn't say it wasn't handsome
but what did you say oh you have a
scraggly [ __ ] i want you no it's okay i
don't think i'm handsome that's nice of
you you always you always raise me up
and i appreciate it you raised me
not that we haven't asked now another
thing i'm noticing and i want to be
clear i want to be crystal clear please
i actually really like this couple of
grays in the beard no no no no no no no
no no no
you can pull it off it looks a salt and
pepper-ish beard on him looks good he
has a little bit of grace too and it
looks good it looks mature
it's sexy it's it's um it's gruff yeah i
like it i appreciate that i appreciate
that tells the story tells a story about
it and it says i'm stressed does it look
like yeah
it does
just so you know the grace started
coming out in the last two years only
it does say i'm surprised i looked in
the mirror the other day and i was like
i look stressed constantly you know what
i get most of the time now and i never
got this before in my life and and tell
me how tired you have to look
for it to happen often when you see
someone they go
you look tired yeah yeah you got to look
real tired right yeah i never got that
before in my life i get that all the
time now and i look at them and i go i
am and i guess i just am it saw my face
no but i think that first of all those
are people that have too much energy i
think you have nice feelings you know
what i mean i think somebody who says
you look tired is because they're on
crack right what i do what i look i feel
tired oh we're gonna crash those people
are gonna [ __ ] crash and i never even
thought about this but it's again social
media what happens it's it's devilish
somebody said to me a couple of days ago
hey you need to start moisturizing you
have wrinkles in your forehead i've
never even thought now i look at
everybody no wrinkles in his forehead
baby
i got it
look at these lines that i have they
said it's too much but i didn't even
think about that but let me ask you let
me ask you something you guys don't get
sent to any skin products that's not
advertising for you we um i i buy skin
products yeah you moisturize i do you
moisturize i moisturize yeah now i have
to moisturize moisturize i do even toner
sometimes what does that mean like uh it
it
it it restores the natural uh balance
sometimes i've never done it once
no you don't but how old are you now 37
my age started showing for me right
right after it sounds like you said my
age started showing for me
you got that test here too yeah yeah
yeah
i swear to god just since the two years
of the pandemic i started seeing like a
little bit of age on me and then you
started moisturizing and then and i
started moisturizing and the great
routine what do i have to do guys for my
skin care routine you should
use a face wash yeah face wash standard
non-apricot scrub
well it's a scrub is it an exfoliating
scrub i don't know you don't want to use
that all the time eating every day okay
don't wash your face every day don't
wash your hair every day doesn't it wash
your front daddy on his face oh yeah
it's a scrub daddy on my face
yeah he thought it was at something for
his face it was it's for pots and pans
is that true the scrub daddy you ever
seen on the uh it's like the dollar
thing the brillo thing wow yeah that
sounds full it looks good yeah okay you
can do that once a week you're going to
want to do a first of all what's your
complexion what's your natural
complexion is it oily is it dry is it
mix i would say oil combination it's
oily i would say i'm an oily so you get
yourself a
face wash that's for oily skin that's
number one
then every every like what once a week
twice a week you exfoliate get out of
the shower you put on a bit of toner
okay and then you're gonna want to
moisturize after that yeah you could
even uh you could even do a serum uh as
well a serum yeah i don't know if the
serum goes before or after the toner so
how about this i'll exfoliate on days i
wash my hair
yeah great great on those days i'll
exfoliate i'll wash my hair i'll take
the garbage out i'll do it on i'll i'll
do it on a garbage can
that's a good way to remind yourself
i want to see you doing it though i want
you to days and fridays tuesdays and
fridays is when you're washing your hair
and you're tomorrow it's garbage day
also exfoliating day wash the hair day
yeah that's the new skincare routine
with me i will i'll i'll do all my
chores with the serums you drop it on
and go to bed is that what happens um
yeah i think so but you put a
moisturizer on it the moisturizer is
always the last thing that's like do you
use anything yeah i moisturize do you
moisturize no i didn't know that holy
smokes also chris upward motion
upward motion motion because it yeah
because
yeah
there's like an uh you want to go up
with it really and it'll turn my face
immediately
in weeks i'll start noticing an
improvement
it'll turn my face
is that a question
uh yes okay yeah yeah although people
keep telling
us that we look like i look tired
you know i'm on my fourth uh eye cream
now because i read the reviews and it's
like oh yeah eye cream goes on too after
the yeah and when you're doing the eye
cream bro check this out you don't ever
rub your eyes i learned this
light
can i use a woman's creams can i use
jasmine stuff absolutely yeah that has
to be specifically for a man no no you
can use it you should buy your own leave
jasmine alone so should i google woman
so okay so because it says moisturizer
creates a barrier between your skin and
the climate okay
including cold dry air that can further
dry out the skin moisturizing also helps
to rehydrate and enhance the capacity of
the skin told water so it's like
gatorade for your face
it locks in moisture bro yeah if you
haven't staten island you need a
moisturizer you don't want a dry face
you want a wet face yeah no you want to
wet your face
you want to moisturize it
you don't want to waffle i want to walk
clip it
see i think you're gonna get sent some
[ __ ] now you gotta we're better yeah
yeah better i mean well well let me tell
you something the eye stuff not shaped
my friend
you can get some stuff for like cvs at
like 10 to 20 dollar range but you got
to get does people some people react
great to retinol some people have a
breakout from retinol okay and you
basically got to go through the products
and try them and see which works best
for you i'm on my fourth expensive eye
cream
in about a year and a half right and you
read the things and they're like this is
unfucking believable i used it for four
weeks i see the difference blah blah
blah blah i've used four different
creams at a top rate i haven't seen any
difference
i'm being honest with you i'm just
thinking out loud now i don't even wash
my face i just let the water hit my face
i don't think i actually wash my face i
get in i get a washcloth i put the soap
on the washcloth which is like i just
use the five in one soap it's it's it's
body wash shampoo conditioner toothpaste
it's everything it's just like the
beginning you're getting older now and
now you've got to start getting
individual things for individuals don't
treat yourself no i'm your time you got
a pinky ring
i've been starting yoga because i was
told by my yoga instructor that she said
to me look chris you're at an age now
where this is almost more important than
lifting weights and and as as important
as eating right because your body is
just it's if you're 37 it turns a corner
she's like i can feel the rigidity in
your muscles yeah and and i was like
yeah so maybe now i got to start
stretching and i got to start using eye
creams and she told me to drink less
coffee i got to start i just got
stressed as long as you don't start
feeling the rigidity in your attitude
you know no
my attitude will always be flexible and
it will always be moist your attitude
will always be more i always have a more
hydrated yes
attitude yeah that's right a wet ass
attitude
but
let me ask you a question what was the
wet ass [ __ ] of our day
the why was it like two live crew what
was the controversial like my mom i
remember one time i was playing two live
crew on my stereo my room the one with
like the two tape decks that kind of
thing and my mom would be like i do not
want you listening to this and i was
like i am old enough to understand that
this is just a song i'm not going to go
out how old are you johnny 32 you're 32
i'm 37 sounds worth 43. it was just
swept dropped down my bar 45. yeah babe
thanks that's a nice reaction for me
that's nice because i'm
there was one little throw away when i
in the middle of a joke on stage i'd be
like you know i turned 30 years old um
november 2006. and then everybody kind
of left but they believed i was 30 for
that little second before i hit him with
the with the misdirect now i do the joke
and i go you know i turned 30 years old
and they just immediately start laughing
yeah and i'm like oh that's a telltale
sign that i have now ages
yeah but what let me say our
controversial songs of the past well see
we got some controversial songs up but i
think that the controversial song the
wet ass [ __ ] version of at least my
generation i would think was my neck my
back lick my [ __ ] and my sure well
that's what i was told i couldn't listen
to at home oh see mine's way before that
mine's like two live crew like uh
oh
what do we got dirty christina aguilera
dirty this was yeah this was pornography
well that was that dirty
is that this
is that that one it's about time no
that's not it i i is that that one i'll
be honest
yeah but that's a pop song she's not
cursing on that is she
well no it was the video that was
graphic at the time oh okay yeah but i'm
talking about graphics
it is by the way oh yeah did you do you
remember her remember her maxim or
whatever cover it is she was in when she
was in the pool
christina yeah with like she was in like
a tube in the pool um that's fine well
that's that's one way to spell it maxum
maximum
one more yeah that one
wow
yep yeah and then she was one yeah yeah
yeah yeah holds up yeah made me love
pools
[Laughter]
two live crew that was shot here
zoo live crew was like um
uh me so horny remember that yes
yeah
i mean that was the wap of my day really
accidental racist i've never even heard
of that song brad brad paisley
what that's controversial i don't know
brad paisley this is an accident i mean
accidentally can we get the lyrics on
that accidental racist
i never heard of it do you know country
music it's really brutal this song is
pretty brutal brutal in what way
i think i remember this getting douche
chills reading this bag
to the man that waited on me at the
starbucks down on main i hope you
understand when i put on that t-shirt
the only thing i meant to say
is i'm a skinnard fan uh-oh
maybe it had one of those um
uh
yeah no no the
the no no no you know the flag the uh
the general lee the uh
confederate flag yes the red flag on my
chest somehow is like the elephant in
the corner of the south and i just
walked him right in the room
just a proud rebel son with an old can
of worms
looking like i got a lot to learn but
from my point of view i'm just a white
man coming to you from the southland
trying to understand what it's like not
to be
i'm proud of where i'm from but not
everything we've done and it ain't like
you and me can rewrite history
our generation didn't start this nation
we're still picking up the pieces
walking on eggshells fighting over
yesterday and caught between southern
pride and southern blame
he really thought he was solving
problems with yeah you can tell he was
like
dialogue i mean i don't know i don't
know i mean if it has a catchy tune
this is my neck my back
so all right so i guess what this is his
like uh kind of uh have you guys ever
bridged the gap kind of you guys ever
heard the song where kanye and t.i rap
at each other why trump's good or bad
yeah yeah yeah no that's insane
or bad yeah yeah that's an insane one i
was just in atlanta last week and ti
starting stand up so i was looking for
atlanta i was looking for ti on stage oh
i saw t.i on stage
what is ti stand for
we don't know
structure was he just flailing was it
he i couldn't tell if there was any
structure a lot of confidence for not a
ton of wristbands sure sure did the
crowd was he bombed let's just be honest
here was it was the full bomb it was a
game and he was like i'm gonna do 45. i
have 45. he said confidently apparently
before he went on stage but it was it
was a showcase at the very end yeah he
went at the very end he followed tony
rock absolutely annihilated and where
was this at the comedy store at the
laugh factory like the laughing any bomb
hard for 45 minutes yeah but it was
weird because i don't think he thought
that
yeah
that's cool yeah most people there's
there's there's a difference you know
we've seen that all the time you know
with stand-up comedy i've seen it for
the last 10 12 years i've been doing it
there's always a person that there's a
delusion there where they'll go on and
absolutely bomb for 30 minutes be like i
killed because they they hang on to that
one laugh which is a beautiful thing i
wish i had that confidence me i'm the
opposite i can do very well and just
hang on to the moment that didn't work
and i'm dead on the floor for for two
weeks i know that that makes you better
than the guy who thinks he's crushing i
think right i have zero confidence
there are there we talked about this
there are like my open micros i see open
mic is coming in and they have
confidence that i wish i had
but it's a slippery slope because
sometimes i think the more confident you
there you have to hit it right in the
balance of confidence because if it goes
into arrogance which it sounds like ti
does then it goes into megalomania and
narcissism then it's like you're not
doing anything like you're never going
to reach your goals like he's never
going to be a huge stand-up comic
because people if he's bombing for like
that even his die hard fans they're just
not going to pay again and again again
jerry seinfeld said it it the the lore
of you wears off in stand up in five
minutes you have five minutes to beat
jerry seinfeld t.i probably has 90
seconds to cti and then we don't care i
was just gonna but then he also has 45
minutes to beat the obviously
it takes 45 seconds to figure out wait
yeah
he could also what he should start doing
is if he wants to really go on stage and
no one's laughing i would just go out
there with my bodyguards behind me and
have guns pointed out the audience yeah
for you
right that's what i would do is he the
one that owns a diamond uh a diamond
mine now and he was like that's not that
was a con oh okay akon oh yeah he's a
good guy okay oh we do okay he's good
he's a good kid no actually well here's
the thing i didn't him and his wife do
something kind of [ __ ] up i learned
after the fact did they yeah they did
they kind of like did a joint me too
against some people
maybe that's why
i was going to stand up
is that why though because he's a he's a
disney like a gold artist or whatever
they call them well rappers can't get me
too that's an impossible it doesn't
happen you can't because if you just
look at any rap lyric ever written it's
a it's all of me too it's like it's
insane that people like there's a tweet
we found from 12 years ago where you
were making a joke it didn't go right
you have no job and then it's like
snoop dogg is the face of every single
product right now in the world
tweets are horrifying
you just go back and listen how can you
hold someone accountable for one joke
tweet and not someone for a body of work
that's why i i've mentioned this before
the most ironic thing i ever saw was
when they canceled uh um uh kevin hart
they wouldn't host the oscars but that
very show they had eminem performing so
kevin hart gets homophobic tweets but
eminem homophobic lyrics saying he wants
to kill his wife put in her trunk
they're like woohoo awards
yeah it's it's none but we know by now
that none of it's real and you know
whatever dude we're on our way to
communism
[Laughter]
did he say anything about like hey
i'm ti and i'm trying this out because
like i'm new here in this space because
or i want to do comedy because
no i'm not even sure what was going on
okay he just came out started doing bits
or did he do bits without knowing very
slowly i mean yeah i mean i guess there
were premises somewhere but i was kind
of just so nervous i just get so
uncomfortable for him
for him he's not uncomfortable but i'm
like i don't know that i can handle it
guys you got a bomb that's what i think
makes a great comment because how
gracefully they can bomb yeah i mean he
was yeah he was just he was chilling
there and really like owning the silence
but never landing it anywhere and and
you didn't see that reflected in his
face whatsoever
like when no one was like did the people
think
i think he was okay
did the people stay all 45 minutes like
was he walking anyone people yeah people
were walking was he dropping or was he
the headliner um i i'm not sure what the
[ __ ] was going on but yeah he yeah he
did show up at the end right and
honestly if i'm ever on a show with ti's
on when i go up after him i'm just gonna
sing his songs me too what is the most
famous i'm gonna give him the old
switcheroo hands go
that's a great ludicrous
you were at the show when fat joe uh did
stage time were you at that show at
caroline's no how was that this was in
2014. uh uh fat joe
said he wanted to come up on on on my
show in 2014 at caroline's and he wanted
to do a set and he did like nine minutes
of this crazy mike tyson story but it
was fantastic but you know he
said the f word a million times and just
had never been on stage before so he was
telling this story like way too quick
and it was not going well at all and
then at the end he did two seconds of
lean back crowd went nuts and they got
off
yeah i think mike cannon might have been
the host who no i didn't even know you
guys yet i thought you were at that show
with with fat joe i i don't think i
would i thought a weekend of headlining
shows at college maybe you could come to
the next one i i think i've seen fat joe
do something though at a scifi show oh
okay yeah yeah and he told the story too
shout out joey crack joey crack that's
his name joey that's what he's oh joey
that's his altar yeah joey cracks and
it's not because of crack it's because
his ass crack hangs out of his pants no
that's why that's what he said
that's why he's known after crack in the
neighborhood did you guys see everyone
was trolling him for the outfit he wore
the other day they were telling him to
dress his age fat shell yeah watch what
do you mean you can't fat first of all
he's like medium joe he's medium joe now
he moisturizes for sure that's more
head twice a week yeah i mean look at
that do i have an old aged face
okay he's more like now he's more like
slim uh lose a little bit joe like slim
down
i think i've said this maybe on hey babe
or on chrissy chaos but fat joe when i
was working with him in 2014 he said he
lost all his weight the only thing he
changed in his diet is he stopped
drinking soda and started drinking black
cherry seltzers and he lost 100 pounds
wow that's the secret he had 100 pounds
and cola weighed on that's what it is
i have a controversial daycare i i think
he's had like some cheek implants or
something whoa he does have craziness
what everyone's making fun of telling
him to dress his age that's the moon
boots thing we talked about two episodes
i don't think they would have said it if
he wasn't wearing the boots right that
outfit with sneakers
no problem tim's you wouldn't have
blinked i mean listen dude i i i don't
want to say i like them i understand
he's a fashionista you know what i mean
i'm wearing a sweatshirt from macy's so
but that's that too that's ageism man
that's why look that's why if he wears
what he wears until the end they're like
oh god this is an old guy he wears old
[ __ ] then you put on something like
dress your age well which one do you
want i'm done with ageism i think it's
horrible i think we need to start
putting some moisturizer on society
that's right that's what i'm saying get
rid of that wet ass society white ass
society wow
[Laughter]
babe i've been using current i
downloaded current and it's connected to
my debit account i get my paychecks
faster i i there's hardly any fees so
you talk about it i'm chrissy current
yeah yeah who is who are they i'm gonna
why don't you tell out current currents
mobile app and connected debit card help
you get ahead by giving you faster
access to paychecks
fewer fees and more flexibilities you
earn points on every butt swipe
redeemable for cash back rewards you
create savings goals including an
ability to round up purchases babe no
withdrawal fees and over 40 000
uh
uh in network all point atms that's a
lot
of money out anywhere there are no fees
for this feature or balance minimum
requirements to access and you can
seamlessly transfer money between
savings and their spending balance no
lockout periods which is big and for a
limited time we've partnered with
current to give away a grand a cool g
that's right current is gonna give away
250 to four listeners of hey babe all
you have to do is download the current
app at current.com hey babe remember
that's current.com hey babe giveaway
will close on april 20th so don't wait
download the current app and be entered
to win at current.com
hey babe no purchase is necessary to win
purchase won't increase chances of
winning void where prohibited
uh eligibility restrictions apply visit
current.com
terms and conditions would you like to
get a little disclaimer let's do a
little disclaimer let's do it quick
current is a financial technology
company not a bank banking services
provided by visa debit card issued by
choice financial group member fdic
pursuant to a license from visa usa
income incorporated and can be used
everywhere visa debit cards are accepted
the annual percentage yield api for
current interest is variable and may
change at any time the disclose api is
effective january 1st 2022 no minimum
balance required must have point once
have one cent in
7.01.01 in savings pods to earn current
interest on up to 2000 deposits per
savings pot up to 6 000 total please
refer to current interest terms and
conditions 60 times 60 time rate
calculated using the fdic average
national deposit rate for savings
accounts of six cents 0.06 0.06 man
these ads are fun
[Laughter]
all right here we go let's go oh we got
to still do the other things hello fresh
okay i got i got until like 3 10. yeah
let's do it all right here we go all
right all right uh what is this beam
this is beam we love
you this is the one you talking about
do i love beam
i got a cbd coco
powder beam it's right by my my little
espresso machine yeah every night when
i'm on good rest i just take a scoop i
put it in some hot water and i i
drink a soothing delicious cup of cocoa
with cbd and i go lights out and you'll
be in hot water with the family if
you're not drinking bean bean is what
you got to get it is a their dream
powder is the best selling uh thing they
have it's a healthy hot cocoa it loves
it and here's why it works our bodies
have an endocannabinoid system or a
highway of communication between the
brain and the body which cbd is
specifically designed to work with 98
percent of 98 of people surveyed falsely
faster when taking beam dream and 99 of
people experience better sleep quality
and people don't realize that you need
good sleep
i got to get my eight hours in i'm sorry
yeah yeah i do and beam's premium nano
cbd dramatically increases your body's
ability to absorb cbd making their
products the most effective in the
wellness space find out why forbes and
new york times are talking about beam
and why it's trusted by the world's top
athletes like danica patrick and baker
mayfield don't love it well then guess
what it will give you your money right
the [ __ ] you get your money back
for a limited time get 20 off when you
go to beamorganics.com
hey babe and use code hey babe at
checkout that's b-e-a-m-organics.com
hey babe use code heybay for 20 off oh
hello fresh it's america's number one
meal kitten we love them to pieces i
love it so much i mean their beef
tenderloin and cheese fondue
is amazing i mean i i'm a founder father
i got the bolognese spaghetti i got the
mozzarella chicken i brought it here
today oh you brought the
in a little fresh
bag with all the ingredients in it got
your protein in there and it comes with
a card with the recipe on the card it's
fun it's colorful it's easy to follow i
made it two nights ago honestly i'm at
the point now where hellofresh is so
good and their discounts are so good and
it saves you 72 percent uh it's 70
cheaper than a restaurant meal it saves
you over 65 a month when you order hello
fresh instead of grocery shopping i'm at
the point now where if you are not
ordering hellofresh you're blocked in my
phone block block baby the over 50 menu
items okay every week you can choose
from veggie fit and fit and wholesome
family friendly they have gourmet
options there's tons of variety okay
we use it he uses it we're using it
today we're actually going to film a
little thing today we're gonna film it
today your mother uses it everybody uses
it your mother uses it it's the best if
you and the discount is insane go to
hellofresh.com slash hey babe 16 and use
code hey babe 16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts dude i'm telling
you when my daughter asks for a sweet 16
i'm gonna say just go to hellofresh.com
and use the code hey babe16 that's your
gift yeah plus three free gifts on top
of that that's what it is what do you
want i ain't made of money 16 free meals
what is hella fresh the government it is
and uh the literally the three best
words in lexicon america's number one
male kid well it's four words yeah i
also sing um
what else does ti sing ti
[Music]
oh you could do whatever you like oh
okay i know but he doesn't sing that one
that's uh slap that
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
i don't know look like another dog
yeah it is right okay all right okay all
right swagger like us okay
yeah the thing is with t.i i know
everything about i know you just you've
heard his songs a million times he just
body slammed someone into the crowd at
one of his concerts that was acting up
i think he didn't actually i think he
called someone up and then picked him up
and then threw them back into the crowd
you know what i mean i mean i don't know
who did you deserve for that no t.i body
slams
no that might have been fat joe
i think he like jumped into the crowd
then body slams rapper ti at right now
is only like 40 years old but well we
got to get back to also what they were
accused of because it's pretty crazy
okay what were they accused of
what where what were t.i and his wife
what is her name pinky tiny tiny tiny
what are ti and and tiny
ti accused of saturday
that's what pimpro ti accused of sexual
articles all like how about how sexual
he is
i'm accused of being sexual subscribe
now one dollar for six months
at that point what are they really
making man come on come on oh he also
got brought up to his name clifford
harris so he didn't get brought up to ti
so people were really confused oh
god and he wasn't bald so yeah people
were like so at first it takes a second
like is that t.i yeah and he's not
saying yeah it's me t.i that i kind of
respect actually i respect that part
about him yeah yeah but then they're
like who is this harris doing 45 years
so he served 11 months in prison the way
some people just do prison like imagine
11 months of your life in prison like
how they talk about like it's nothing by
the way yeah some people they're like i
did an 11 year bid fat joe did nine
months in jail like you would never he
doesn't even like that would be i would
wear it on me like you want to talk
about age face now i mean i would forget
he looked better yeah that's when he
started started drinking black cherry
seltzers i would say he's allegedly
accused of stuff allegedly
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay
so
that was our that was allegedly we
should be doing every week here on hey
every thursday we're gonna do one
allegedly a week so i don't know and
then we'll just yeah we usually do
that's what we do oh speaking of uh
allegedly allegedly tom brady
allegedly tom brady might be coming back
at a retirement he might be coming back
into retirement and i want to give a
quick congratulations to matthew
stafford los angeles rams they beat a
hell of a team joe burrow the cincinnati
bengals they got a young team their
scrappy team yeah okay and they're gonna
be in it for a while to come okay
they're gonna be a quick shout out
that's not to take anything away from
tom brady who won the super bowl with
the tampa bay buccaneers ignore our boy
patrick mahomes who had a really tough
loss
and so basically
patrick mahomes and joe burrow on these
two teams that lost this year that are
really on the up and coming and we we're
really going to give him a shout out
good common theme between matthew
stafford and tom brady both won the
super bowl at their home stadiums
unbelievable unbelievable
so
yep i agree yes
um
flight attendant i'll tell you something
later you'll get it later on
flight attendant subdues disorderly
passenger by hitting him over the head
with a coffee pot allegedly
um
not to get hit over there with a coffee
pot that can't feel good
i mean i mean hot coffee one time
jasmine had a pot of tortellini like she
had cooked it was fully cooked the pot
of tortellini she was about to take it
and pour the tortellini into the
strainer and then serve it and the
handles broke off of the pot and all
these spalding hot tortellini and a pot
fell on her bare feet
like immediately fell in her bare feet
just about a year ago she literally it
was one of those things where
i saw she goes oh [ __ ] and then she
falls to the floor and it was silent and
then i think it was like a delayed
reaction and then it was the biggest
scream i've ever heard out of here oh my
god i don't want to look at my feet i
don't want to look at my feet the skin's
burnt off the skin's burnt off and then
i was like it was crazy i like ran to go
help her slipped in the in the
tortellini water and then it turned out
like her feet were okay like she had
like a second-degree burn it's like a
sunburn on her feet but i remember the
pain of of just water on her feet right
scalding hot coffee over your head
has to be worse
right what would they say a tortellini
bowl to the feet or coffee pot to the
head oh definitely uh tortellini to
defeat yeah really you should actually
pour totally any water on your feet
twice a week yeah
it helps with the roughness
remember we saw that guy go crazy on the
plane
oh my god we saw a guy me and pimpy saw
a guy reece reese reese witherspoon
we saw a guy this is what a week ago
yeah last weekend the plane was landing
like was fully like you know like when
you're landing on the runway like it was
you know going 400 miles an hour some
what was he a 90 year old man yeah he
was he was a nine-year-old man eyes
going he was he was not with us like you
know what i mean like i'd be shocked if
he's alive a week later not he was like
a dying man yeah nine-year-old man
starts walking towards the bathroom
and this flight attendant is like sir
sit down sit down we're in actually
taxiway and he's like um
and then so
we're like what is happening she goes
sir you need to sit down it is not safe
and then he's not saying anything so
there was an empty seat in front of her
so she goes sir and she moved in and she
goes just sit sit here and he goes
and then he goes to sit there like goes
look sits there waits for her to be out
of his way and just continues towards
the bathroom so she gave up and she was
like is this his emergency and he just
kept going mm-hmm
and then he went
into the bathroom yeah and we had never
seen anything like that i mean the
flight attendant started laughing
eventually but we were like we i didn't
know but what the thing that we learned
though is when they say you can't get up
because in
active taxiway you can't get up seat
belts on nobody can go to the bathroom
sorry that's kind of bs it is because if
it's an emergency they have to let you
go even if you get active taxi when you
get stuck on the runway for two hours
they really feel like it's did you want
me to [ __ ] in the seat yeah then they'll
say no yeah i didn't know that i thought
like literally they'll pull a gun out
and shoot you in the head
they act like they do they flex like
they do though no they you're like
yeah you know what's even better was
that woman remember that crazy woman
when we were boarding oh my god that's
all just like another 80 year old woman
i'm done with old people on planes
like being an old person is great though
you can do whatever you like
you can do it
he should come out to that when he's
going to do up
i love it so
you're done with old people on planes
he was an 80 year old woman you were
going to eight-year-old woman and she
was you know she was like running as
fast as she could you know the flight
was not going to board for another
minute she's like hold the plane please
hold the plane i don't know what gate
i'm at well before that she said i'm
here guys don't worry yeah and we were
like what and then
it's one of those things where it's like
listen i know old people have to travel
too but it's like if you're over 70 like
why are you what are you even traveling
for
that's bleak though
seven my parents are 70 and 75.
they should have ankle bracelets on
i'm kidding you know what's a sad moment
when you're like i shouldn't drive
anymore that's gotta be a sobering sad
moment let's bring this whole podcast
down to depressing [ __ ] how about this
an airline just for old people that'd be
good they oh my god i was 45 minutes
late oh my god you're on to something
the seats are toilet seats yes yeah it's
a commode ever there's five commodes i
like that actually a lot
if you're over 75 you can only fly or
maybe not only but we have an airline
just for you like like how they have
retirement homes you can't go in there
if you're 55 and over right why not have
a retirement airline i really think that
that's a good business it's a good
business we should think about it i'm
honestly i'm down to do it yeah you know
i have a pinky ring on i really don't i
feel kind of unstoppable to be honest
and i'll pay for the airline in cash
[Music]
have you been on stage have you been on
stage with the pinky ring on you no but
that's tonight oh tonight is the nine
team
2001 or something 97
now they know it it's usually a secret
it's one of the things they like most
about it we'll hit them with it they
don't know what the we'll do in this
episode i don't know maybe we'll do this
episode first and next week's episode
this week maybe we'll do it
allegedly
all right all right all right there's
the bit it was what it was michigan
police are investigating after a man
reported that his his entire cabin was
stolen
they picked it up that's hilarious to
pick it up with just a forklift and get
out did they do that they literally took
the entire home how is that possible
it's in detroit it says detroit i'll be
there march 4th royal oak michigan
christy comedy.com for tiki wikis nice
there it is
um uh 12 foot by 28 foot cabin was
removed from its lot sometime between
november 18th and december 16th when it
was last seen that's hilarious it's kind
of a weird situation trooper matthew
scott
you think yeah it's only kind of weird
don't worry the weirdest thing
ever we put
and then they go the cabin has a brown
exterior with a white door white trim
and an orangish roof anyone with
international disappearance and don't
worry about this
contact the msd
post at
the cabin was 989-422-5100 seen with a
white door with a white trim the guy
repaints it
they put up missing posters have you
seen like the strangest amber alert on
your phone
i like the guy who's not see the story
knocks out and the other guy walks open
the door he's like what are you talking
about this is my place
so funny dude i mean listen i mean i
guess if you're like in the wilderness
like that and you have a forklift or i
guess you could pick it up how long
could you guys live in a cabin like
isolated oh like what do you mean though
what do you mean
you got food in yellowstone like you
have food and stuff but you're in the
middle i mean i have a lovely life in an
isolated cabin wi-fi
no wi-fi
yeah
i'm not going yeah you do need otherwise
you're you're cut off on the world do
you have your loved ones
uh one one person you have one loved one
no wi-fi yeah [ __ ]
who would you pick that joke but only
one loved one
right now you're in a cabin you only
pick one level you bring your mother
your father only one
you gotta choose
oh i don't know maybe your father just
because he can help with wood stuff yeah
yeah that's the reason why i bring my
dad yeah all right dad's not the wood
stuff guy but i hear that i would bring
your dad you would bring my dad well no
my dad can't fix or do anything my dad's
got a horrible need so i i was saying
but sal's dad is out of the way
i drink sal's dad
i i once reported my car stolen at the
woodbridge mall in new jersey shadow
woodbridge yeah it was i was it was like
a it was either a jcpenney or a strauss
hannah strauss no what's that a s or
abrahamic strauss not a answer yes
i parked my car and uh i went back out
and went and went more closed and so the
parking lot was virtually empty and i
knew where i parked my car and that
smells good by the way
like i got a waffle whatever skin cream
yeah there's a lotion on the end well i
just i just got out of the shower hand
soap but whatever was it his hand came
relatively close to me and i you know
went like down his hand smells good yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
it's nice it's nice reported stolen
cops came
cops came i was like it was right here
guaranteed i know it's right here it's
gone like i couldn't believe it i was
like it happened to my mom on super bowl
sunday by the way this super bowl
we went outside and her car was gone
they found it last night what what
where'd they steal it from the driveway
of my grandma's house she did leave the
key in the car the car was unlocked and
the car was gone
wow
but that means someone's going around
searching because you don't just know
that the keys left in the car right that
means wow that's crazy
i was the one who was like i thought we
brought that car here yeah it was just
very confusing moment was it a joyride
did they loot it did they strip it did
they was it okay i don't know that
answer yet we just found out last night
that they found the car
but it was a crazy super what kind of
car was it an audi and now so a nice car
was a nice car wow you got to put one of
those apple air tags in it somewhere you
always know where the car is yeah that's
the best thing that really works
yeah yeah yeah if you put an apple air
tag it's got it's the gps world you can
put it on anything i'll put that [ __ ] on
everything wow put it on your pinky
thieves look out then yeah if i was the
thief if i was in the game yeah now you
got to rethink the whole game
tonight last night again two o'clock in
the morning
alarm goes off in the house i come
downstairs this back door that's sitting
behind you is open this door's open i
said come on come on wow where to go i
said what the hell is going on i don't
know what happened i have no idea we
looked on the cameras nobody was here
nobody was on the property that door was
unlocked accidentally so but this this
door was open like it was fully open so
i don't know if the wind blew this door
open and that door open or something
happened or an animal tried to open this
and then wind blew that because that's
what triggered the alarm but i mean dude
we came down last night like ready to go
like did you come down with a weapon
ready to go yeah i want to know when
that happens what you're in there
you got it you've got to grab the first
two times it's happened this is the
third time my alarms went off in the
middle of the night now it's crazy the
first two times i was truthfully like
scared like really really really scared
something's happened to me like very
recently over the last like two or three
weeks where i've been like i can't be
scared of the dark in my own house i
can't be scared of like that's what
happens this is that's why that's what i
am this is my house it comes it comes
with the boldness that he hadn't had
before i said i'm the man of the house
my daughter's looking at me so i came
down yesterday with a [ __ ] baseball
bat and i was ready to go
hold on you wake up i know all your
jewelry is on a tray like on your
nightstand before you go down you're
like let's get this
out yeah i put that on yeah
and then and then i came down with her
what about the bat
where's the bat the bat i have the bat
we put it right underneath my bed and
then jasmine jasmine came down just like
jasmine didn't need a weapon she just
came down ready to go with rigatoni
yeah she's with toy with potter
tortellini she didn't need a whip on no
way
i like it i like it you could say you
have puerto rico i am half puerto rican
oh um so yeah but it was crazy dude like
some the thing is with if you want to
break into this house
you're going to have to deal with like i
think it's the wrong house to break into
yes i have a pink ring in a baseball bat
jasmine's wild but if tt jerry who's a
food who's a friend of the show if you
don't know tt jerry i i think you did
you i don't know if you saw her when she
was coming in but tt jerry is 25 years
in prison uh transgender uh she just got
out two years ago
she will you know if you pick the wrong
night when she's sleeping over watching
my kids like she will fully she'll like
decapitate you like she has she has told
us you told me multiple times we've
asked her would you ever go back to
prison she said if anyone broke into the
house or hurt you jasmine or the
children i would murder them with my
bare hands or a knife and i'd cut their
head off and go back to prison no
problem they were going to get a
rottweiler but they don't need it we
don't need one so we got a transgender
puerto rican same thing
so
so i i i'm nerv i'm i'm always thinking
about like if someone because i live in
an apartment building right now but i'm
i'm moving to a home and uh i've never
lived in a home completely alone before
and it's now just coming on my radar
that like i
i don't know how i feel about that so i
actually ordered a machete
you did well yeah well yeah well from
it's not an entry-level weapon
no no no no
no
bespoke bespoke post
let us pick something from the catalog
because they were like a sponsor and
they had a machete and so i just took
the machete i was like at least it'll
find a use but then i was thinking to
myself that's committing because like
you could hit someone with a bat and not
and not leave a traumatic scene forever
in your prison for hitting someone with
a machete well not if they're in my
house
you have to prove no this is a law you
have to prove that your back was against
the wall and you could find no other
recourse other than murdering this
person or if not you are just using the
same with a bat
same thing i think just owning a machete
is intent to kill
yeah a little bit
the way they sold it was that it was for
like weed whacking and stuff like that
you know like they're just like going
through like in just you know weed
whacking i suppose yeah that's it yeah
that's what it is you got a murder
weapon in the box of awesome yeah
pretty much but i was thinking though
like it it's gonna be a tough one if
someone breaks it awesome to actually
use the machete on it because i don't
want to be around that no sal i'm going
to be honest with you being on because
i'm same thing with you came from
apartments to now owning a home it's
really like
a lot of guys out there probably maybe
you won't admit this but it's
nerve-wracking when the alarm is going
off at 2am all your kids are up your
family's there and you have to i have to
walk down a flight of stairs in complete
darkness just being woken up it's
terrifying in the apartment it's like
i'm all on one floor like i can just
come out and see what's going on here is
like what am i going to do if there's if
there's two men down there robbing my
house and they want to hog tie up what
am i going to do i can't it's like uh
you know am i going to fight to the
death i have to an apartment you just
jump out a window no problem you got
other people though that's what i'm
saying yeah you know like it's it's it's
also like i was so used to my whole life
opening the door and scanning visually
scanning my living space in one i could
just see it all like now it's like
there's multiple floors even when we
come in late at night i'm like i don't
know if there's somebody in the basement
oh right you don't even know if there's
somebody waiting no we don't know at all
listen we have the security so we can
always see coming in and out but it's
have you guys ever seen like uh the
viral videos of the woman living in the
fall ceiling in somebody's house no can
we pull that up i'll try to take it up
the food was disappearing out of the
fridge so they put a nest cam in dude
that's uh that movie uh what's it called
parasite parasite yeah nice that that
happened to people
yeah every movie is based on in reality
yeah we saw recently we saw someone
living under someone's porch for like 10
years remember yeah and they just
recently got caught come on you know two
out of three men what they're going to
experience what mark's experiencing
right now pattern baldness mark so you
use keeps and it works right oh yeah i
love it yeah
there it is yeah yeah
he was using it you know you could use
it where you like we're all experiencing
it i got a little bit two out of three
men experienced some form of healing we
had a three-year-old at 35. more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern borderlands now keeps helps you
keep what you have yes it's only two fda
approved medications like your friend
hairlord's keeps has both of them both
okay
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
even leave the home they got 24 7 karen
support with a network of
medical advisors experts prescribers and
care specialists to support you and
making your hair goals a reality uh the
cost is low relatively for sure
treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month that's it offers generic versions
again of the only two fda approved
medication to prevent hair loss they
have everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door and
discreet packaging proven results
remember guys prevention is the key stop
it right now keep what you have
treatments take four to six months
though they do take four to six months
so get spending now get get get prepared
now when it comes to hair save more
spend less if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to ke
hey babe to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash hey babe get your first month
for marie
keps.com hey babe all right man you know
me you know i love bean baby b-e-a-m
it's everything to me i get sleep look
at my hair dude i'm sleeping right now
because i just had some beam dude it is
the best sleep aid first of all did you
know that poor sleep causes weight gain
mood issues and poor mental health maybe
that's why i'm fat maybe it's not the
fettuccine alfredo i'm eating at two
o'clock in the morning maybe it's
because i'm not sleeping but beans can
make me skinny and beam dream beam is
the world's most innovative functional
wellness brand with unique products for
everything from sleep to recovery and
today
my listeners get a special discount
available for beam sleep product the
dream powder which bro
me and sal drink the dream powder i mean
you just pass out it's seriously the
sick and tastes good it's a hot cocoa
it's the best 98 of people survey fall
asleep faster when taking bean dream and
99 of people experience better sleep
quality if you don't love it you get
your money back then it's guaranteed for
a limited time get twenty dollars off
when you go to beam organics dot com
slash hey babe and use the code hey babe
at checkout that's b e a m organics dot
com slash hey babe and use code hey bay
for 20 off go to sleep you should
probably check like the floorboards and
stuff you know dude i know i know well
we're getting new floors put in in the
basement um uh because we have a leak so
i'm going to ask that the guys doing
that floor work to see if there's any
holes in the in the basement floor when
was the last time you were in a dust up
like a little a little
scuffle yeah a scuffle like a
putting my hands on someone when was the
last time you ever had to like actually
uh
throw down a little bit
i didn't have to throw down well i think
i told you like a month ago by the way i
just love how did you always do this no
[Laughter]
i want to kind of show the people that
i'm a changed man and yeah this is me
hater you know like me or i don't care
this is what it's going to be from now
on just based on this no one will break
into this guy's house do it because
here's the thing is is i'm going to come
in and and you know i made some
investments i've invested in a local uh
trash collecting company yeah that's
what i have now i have a private garbage
company that's going to come on and
we're going to take garbage from all
your guys houses this is what it is i've
i've made a decision to really embrace
staten island no you haven't yeah now
we're being facetious
with the pinky ring i cannot tell yeah
that's the thing literally can't tell
it's gonna be like god bless you i will
invest in like some type of mozzarella
company or something
by the way god bless you god bless new
merch babes
staten island new york and sal's phone
number seven eight five five five five
five high five
oh sorry about that this is apparently
the footage of the woman coming out
so she's in oh she sneaks out for the
food in the middle of the night oh
oh my god
how does she get in and out of the house
though or did she just stay in the house
she never leaves the house never leaves
the house how did she get there to begin
with
she was living in the ceiling this could
oh that is creepy as fudge
but
that's [ __ ] creepy dude that's creepy
creepy you know what's one of the
creepiest scenes it looks like the right
like the freaking ring like that's
insane
no
that's hilarious
do you know what's one of the well she
looks like
when did she piss in this what would you
do if you caught someone drinking
[ __ ] nuts if you thought someone
drinking out of your milk in the middle
of night what would you even do
i would wage a full-on war where's she
going there i would i would take out the
machete
i would at least try to scare them
dude you know what's one of the
creepiest scenes of any movie and it's
subtle but it's so creepy i think about
this all the i was actually thinking
about it last night when i was coming
down the stairs for some reason
i think it's one of the i think it's the
second blair witch project not the first
one the second one there's a scene where
they have like a camera in the bedroom
and the wife who's possessed just gets
up and is staring at the wall for it
says four hours she just gets up and is
looking at the wall for four hours it's
the cree it just gives me the chills
that's in manhattan this is in manhattan
i didn't realize that really it's free
that's oh my god i guarantee you the
woman who lives in the ceiling does open
mics in new york city yeah i guarantee
you
every sunday every sunday but did so
what did you say you had a scrap
so the scrap was so i think a month
maybe two months ago some like you know
new york city is kind of getting like
i've never ever in my life in new york
city ever had a scuffle dust up with a
homeless person or crazy nothing i mean
seen it whatever but never really in my
jurisdiction
about a month two months ago i was
walking in the comedy cellar
and
some guy
you know crazy i assume homeless comes
up to me and is like yo can i have a
dollar and i was like i'm sorry man i
don't have any i just kept walking this
is like the common response in new york
if i had a dollar i would give it to you
he goes you're not gonna give me a
dollar and keeps following me and i was
like i'm sorry bro i don't have it i was
like you have a venmo like you know like
kidding around yeah
and and i was like i would you know but
i don't have a dollar and he was like he
was like well go to the atm and get me
some money man and i was like i can't do
it i'm i can't i don't know why i
engaged in that long and then he like
cut like came around and like cut me off
and i just immediately like to full hand
pushed him over like a pile of garbage
like he went far like this is right by
the ace hardware store you know what i'm
talking about by the village underground
piles of garbage there and i just full
pushed him like with all my might and he
like flipped like barrel rolled over
this pile of garbage he was like that
was [ __ ] up man and then he like ran
down the block and i was like that's the
first time in my life that i wow yeah
it's crazy because that really was a
dust up that was a dust stuff but i mean
like i was you know like to be honest if
he would have attacked me i think i
would have made a split decision like
if he didn't have a weapon like maybe i
would have just ran i don't want to deal
with this guy but he physically like ran
away and people outside that 7-11 were
like this guy's harassing people all day
because the cops now though it's
changing with the nypd now there's just
a unit now that's like going around and
being like
we have we have no choice now the city's
just not i mean some woman got murdered
in her hallway uh in the lower east side
a week ago so now the cut the nypd is
like well now we have to go back to just
like really enforcing the law i started
carrying mace
pepper spray pepper spray how's he doing
yeah
what oh you said you started carrying
mace yeah yeah i thought you meant the
wrapper now yeah it's okay you should
get a satchel for your machetes that
joke yeah i got mixed
pepper spray and machetes now is what
how i do wow that's how i do so you
right now you have pep you have peppers
no no but if i'm going out like you know
and i'm just going to be gallivanting
around yeah into all hours of the night
i keep keeping
my interesting uh i'll tell you uh the
police came to ans
and my car
uh was uh on the other side
of the department
uh it was identical it looked identical
and it was identical and when they got
in the car we were driving and then we
went around and on the other side my car
was the last one in the lot i was like
there it is there it is right there
i couldn't believe it i was i was
it was before cell phones right so i was
in i was like borrowing the the jcpenney
phone to call the police shout out jc
penny yes
i'm a macy's guy but you want to go jc
penney go jc penney i didn't say i was
shopping there i just parked in that
wing there it is
what is jason what does jc penny stand
for jesus christ jesus christ yeah jesus
christ
they're still around jcpenney they go
out of business
i think they're out of business right
wait john are you into aren't you in a
move a tv show right now uh yes the the
big leap on uh it was on fox now it's on
hulu i don't know if it's getting picked
up dude that's sick to be on hulu oh
yeah that was great i bet you more
people are watching on hulu than they
did on fox they did i think they did
it's true gotta be right how about this
ratings don't matter as much anymore no
he was uh
last time i saw him on television with
this season of uh
kirby enthusiasm oh cool multiple
episodes baby episodes of curb that was
good how was that the coolest have you
been asked about it a million times yeah
yeah but i don't care i love it it was
the i mean it was my favorite show
always my favorite i know and ld is my
hero i know i mean that's like getting
imagine ld like for if i don't think
there's anybody in comedy that's like i
don't like larry david if you don't it's
like you know what i mean i know i might
not like larry david
but it's like she's not going to comedy
you know what i mean did she allegedly
allegedly
did you have to did you have to like
what was like when you found out that
you got the audition like well actually
so i got a part on curb like four years
ago
shot a scene and i got cut
and larry called me personally he
personally called me like we don't have
each other's numbers or anything but i
got a call from like wow
and he was like i had to cut you like
you didn't even say hello he's like i
hate to catch you
i'm like oh my god you know don't worry
about he's like but we're gonna have you
back
and uh it was like right after i got
fired from snl too and i got fired and i
had and i had met
him at snl when he was playing bernie
okay and so i knew him a little bit was
it how was that when you got fired from
snl was that a call too
was it fine
no but you get a call from lauren
michaels no lauren calls you to hire you
but not to fight so who calls you to
fire
my agents i called my agent to tell him
i got ass and i was like because lauren
called me again so i called my agents to
be like i gotta sit down you know what
was that call like when lauren does he
truly just pick up the phone and call
you yeah i was in a parking lot at the
mystic lake casino in minnesota you ever
performed there yeah yeah opening for
julian mccullough okay and uh nightmares
place to perform and i got a call for
more money did you think you were going
to get snl or you really didn't or
didn't not know i wasn't confident i
thought there was a real chance because
i had a good audition and it was like a
good kind of moment
feeling and yeah and i lost my phone and
then he just called you was it like
emotion did you cry actually yeah
i just screamed
sorry
yeah but i mean i support gay people
oh wow did cry honestly dude i would cry
too like that's the thing is like snl
such an iconic show like even though you
know podcasts and obviously sal you know
joker's huge success if lauren michaels
called i think either one of us said he
was like you want to be on snl even
though the money would be down
everything we still i think both of us
be like i really yes i think i do i
would take it i would i would just do it
i was like the draconic yeah snl and
curb were yeah
that's the secret folks you want to have
a successful life don't wash your hair
every time you wash it you're washing
out that success baby if you exfoliate
twice a week you could be on one season
investment
what was the what was the worst part
about being on snl
just bombing bombing at those table
raids was the table reads the worst
live audience what america saw it was
the behind the scenes yeah well
thankfully i never bombed on air that
does happen well bring it up
i did miss an on-air queue no
what was that like yeah and i remember i
even asked keenan i'm like doesn't have
him right he's like oh
i'm supposed to be sitting next to pete
is pete playing peter dinklage
was it was a schedule was it was it like
did they recover quickly or like what
was that
the next second i just i thought they
were going to go to commercial i was
like in my outfit right did people laugh
about it or like in the moment in live
or did you guys laugh because it was
like thought they're like oh maybe
that's the premise of the sketch this
guy's like late
oh my goodness um did you get
reprimanded for that or not really
no but like i went up to lauren and like
apologize but he didn't seem to care
he's like oh this is john hamm or
whatever
[Laughter]
is he like actually like like a personal
person or it's just like there's a
barrier and only a few people kind of
know who he is and that yeah yeah i
think if you're doing well you know with
the show he's you have a different
relationship i think it's one of those
things where lauren may not even
remember you because like i do think
that seriously
i'm not confident he probably wouldn't
remember me whoa i think he probably at
this point thinks bill murray is still
in the show
nerves you first how long before the
nerves got out was it nerves every
saturday night nerves constantly
throughout the entire process and the
bombs i mean they help with stand up
because sure at that point i'm eating
[ __ ] in front of everybody i look up to
right it was just like trump hosted uh
when i was there and
uh
you could hear
a pin drop if not for like the
protesters 17 floors below he was
bombing trump i was bombing doing an
update piece and i could hear the
protesters
17 floors down oh my god that's how
badly yeah do some people everywhere
like when you're bombing on stage we've
all bombed on you know doing stand up do
you can you do that thing we're like
this is bombing to get like a laugh or
you cannot in sketch one you can't right
you can't it's such a tight environment
and you've got to commit even further i
think that the trick is to commit as
much pretend like it's not happening
well does sketches ever get on that
bombed in the room but they got on
anyway that don't do that well in the
room but you can tell that they would do
good on air and same where stuff crushes
a table but doesn't work you know right
with an audience it just works in a room
full of you guys go right back as soon
as that sketches over you're in the back
and look at each other like oh my god
dude that [ __ ] bomb um i well with uh
with live yeah that that will happen
during dress and then it won't go to air
but at a table read
for me
like i get once i would get one sketch
that i wrote right um usually at you
know 4am on my own
panicked out of my mind you know because
you get one night to do it on tuesday
and then table reads on wednesday
and
yeah it would just table that would be
my one opportunity to do well so i would
eat [ __ ] and then i'm just sitting there
for the rest of the time and then maybe
at one point i go uh the president's
here to see you but i'm so you know
nervous i probably shut that up is it
true then because we've heard that
his lauren michael's um strategy is to
keep snl writers and and performers in
the room for as late as possible because
he thinks you know at four o'clock in
the morning is when your brain is the
funniest is there truth to that you
think or that's made up stuff i can't
tell if there's any logic to writing the
show in one night but i think there are
people that thrive in that environment
and they stick around and there are
people that just should get an snl
audition even sale i never even got an
snl edition i don't feel like a real new
york comic at all even though i've done
letterman and had these accomplishments
i feel like because i never even got
asked to even audition not even in like
at the comedy club level like snl has
said no from the from the baby roots
they don't care at all and it hurts
because i'm like i'm a new york guy even
if you told me no at least let me get an
audition yeah you know but i never even
got an audition you ever get an audition
uh i know he probably won't remember
this but
years ago colin said to me you should
audition for us now colin quinn uh colin
got it he said uh you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
he said he just was like you know i've
been thinking i think like you i think
you should be you should audition i
think you should and i was like out of
nowhere organically i don't know where
yeah we were just hanging out with you
something and then uh and then i i was
too i was too
timid to ever follow that up ask him
right now call him up
face timer
yeah so i never did but i would i i
would love i would like to still to this
day i would like to at least just
audition even if they say no and i bomb
just to kind of cross it off let's can i
hey can i have an audition i'm sure it's
not possible nerves walking into the
audition oh my god had to be insane
insane and i was the last one to
test that day and i was like 16th or
whatever oh and it's silent right you do
the whole thing they don't even react
anybody else get it from your test from
your day um my buddy will steven uh is a
writer he's still there okay and he
became a writer but i was the only new
cast member that year wow and you were
dead last
dead last but had a good showing in the
room really i had a good showing in the
room
audition then i didn't but i didn't have
anything else so when i got there i'm
like you know you guys right for me now
and they're like how'd they initially
see you at a comedy club like how does
it work it was jfl that really changed
your for me just for laughs montreal
comedy festival yeah yeah yeah i was uh
i had like a
an audition for jfl i'm like a few years
into comedy i'm opening for santino but
i'm not that good
and in between my audition and my
callback i had come up with this dirty
dancing bit that i did on the show that
was in between the audition and the call
the call back there was like a more like
the signature it was like you know six
weeks or whatever a month or something
um and i just like came up with this
[ __ ] have you seen it you talk on
that worked that did really well and and
by the way you talk about commitment
yeah what's the bit hard so i come out
to the dirty dancing song time in my
life yeah and i have an imaginary
jennifer gray and i do all the
choreography with her and i treat her
you know all real and then i do up to
the lift and then i drop her but she's a
goner and i'm trying to bring her back
now i got to get rid of the body that's
what you audition with that just again
it just goes on for four minutes you
know the cop was calm wasn't killing
cops
for all while the song is playing all
while the song plays
so for my callback for jfl i'm think i'm
not going to get jfl i'm i'm you know
new face is real competitive and i'm not
that good yet
but i was like well they think i'm going
to do these jokes i did for my audition
instead i'm going to go out there i'm
going to put the microphone to the side
i'm going to do this four minute dance
mime act and they'll at least remember
me and then i went to jfl with that i
ended the new faces showcase with that
it went insane snl was there they
invited me to and so within like a few
weeks suddenly i'm honest oh my goodness
at that point in life i'm like i don't
know how i'm gonna
oh my god make it there i don't know
what i'm feeling right now
yeah so and then i was like immediately
headlining i didn't have an hour of
material so it was just kind of like
dude
but that's the thing it's it's even more
than it's
in entertainment and casting for sure
but even in life like you did something
outside the box you i don't think
anybody who is successful life hasn't
taken one at least one humongous swing
and some of them they miss but if you
hit it like you hit it then all of a
sudden you get on the show you know even
you i'm sure you said you guys running
practical jokers on the ferry or
something right like the idea for it
yeah something like that it was like we
went to yeah like [ __ ] it let's take a
swing because i think sometimes when we
sit and think about all the then it's
like your brain's like this should go
wrong not going wrong but if you're just
like hey the gun's at my head right now
i got to do it yeah i think that's a
life less anything in life when it goes
well then you gain some confidence
you're like oh my gosh there's something
to do so it gets knocked back down kids
don't study for your tests out there
just go wing it because i think you'll
at least give interesting answers even
if you fail right and then uh just for
for
curb for curb nerves there
you did it already you kind of knew them
little listeners no definitely nerves
there because it is soft scripted right
right
let me ask oh my god
oh my god let me ask you this question
real quick what had higher nerves was it
this is a tough one was it kirby
enthusiasm on set with larry david was
it snl audition or was it watching t.i
do comedy
i doing comedy
most i've ever shipped
[Laughter]
for sure yeah oh man
you're in scenes with larry right it's
like yeah i mean pretty much all my
scenes are with are you playing the
young i play young lady right because
the other guy got [ __ ]
right and then you got brought in to
replace him yeah yeah
yeah i'm like you know disagreeing with
larry about it and you're in a scene
props i'm like very picky about it yeah
oh yeah larry wouldn't drink out of this
kind of mug he's like
out of this yeah the prop has to want to
murder you too close to larry yeah yeah
a lot of that is improv right on curb
like all improvised other than the
outline of the scene like larry and you
disagree over the mugs you think larry
you know you have a different idea about
the characters is it one of those things
where you do the scene five times and he
takes the best bits yes got it yeah oh
there were so much we would do ten
minute takes you know ten minutes oh
there's so much i wish had made it in
there and then he's like keep this this
and this let's do it again yeah and i
will say so i was really nervous but
then when he broke when he laughed then
i was a lot less nervous okay and that's
like
the greatest moment of my life was
making larry laugh oh my god it's
amazing dude well we hope that we made
you laugh
on this show
this has been hey baby
yeah thank you
for wrapping it up i think our second
guest ever
well third guess we have the [ __ ] queen
brian quinn yeah uh now uh john
krasinski and zinski
rodnick we love you thank you and hulu
they can catch the show big league
anything you want to plug at all
anything i don't know stand up dude
in chicago first weekend of march
yeah we're doing it i love it i love you
guys i love you guys i love you guys
thank you moving in dude please do the
cupboard
dude move into the attic and remember
extra security don't wash your hair kids
this saturday night two days i'll be in
madison wisconsin for two shows at the
barrymore sunday night i am at chicago
at the vic theater for two shows and
then march 11th with christian nashville
and march 12th in chattanooga good dates
christy comedy.com for me we got
tomorrow night at the borgata february
26 atlantic city march 4th royal oak
michigan march 5th gramercy special
taping march 11th of course with sally v
at the ryman
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed